what was your advice for real estate
agents who are just getting started on
YouTube you got to start before you're
ready what if people judge me what if I
get criticism what if I look dumb I
don't really know what to say skill up
and invest in yourself be patient though
these things do take time people are too
hard on themselves they upload four
YouTube shorts they try this for one
week or one month the real key is to
stick with it over time especially
because your competitors they'll be too
busy they won't figure out the systems
to get all this done they will get tired
they will maybe get discouraged if you
can crash through all those quitting
points and persevere it's less about how
great you're going to be at this and the
results you're getting in 6 months it's
more interesting in 16 months develop
your mindset and prepare your mind to
not give up when you don't get quick
results in one day